[Music]
you guys people react to stress in
different ways and
over the last four years of the trump
presidency americans have reported
an overwhelming number of stress-related
symptoms like
insomnia ulcers and rashes and i'm no
exception ever since people started
talking about how trump
isn't going to concede the election
about how he's going to stage a coup
instead i've been having a very specific
physical ailment and frankly
that very specific physical ailment i've
been having
has been given me the blues
[Music]
democracies and shambles
how will we proceed joe biden's got the
votes but
trump refuses to concede
trump is traveling around preaching
violence countrywide
he's trying to steal the liction and
they're stopping me
up inside i'm feeling really pissed
this can't persist i'm full of [ __ ] i
got two
to pools this may be
over-sharing but my fears about
our nation are giving me a big old case
of stress-induced constipation
trump calls votes for ego he tweets
without control
why does my apprehension manifest in
mother cold
i'm feeling really pissed this can't
persist
i'm
[Music]
oh too constipated that's right i got it
oh my god my guts i got you
[Music]
oh crap how are we gonna finish oh
[Music]
i'm feeling really pissed ah my
stomach's in a twist
i've had enough of it god please help me
[ __ ] oh
there's nothing i can do
i
[Music]
[Music]
oh my freaking good
[Music]
[Applause]
you